[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
ah ha so cute oh we're talking about
geniuses sorry I was getting on today's
charity stream and Tom and I are joined
by Elise and James Williams all right
thank you so much for having us know
thank you for having us
um and we're also gonna do something a
little bit different
wait voice of God Eric take can you
please lower the Sims it's too high
[Music]
thank you we are gonna do something a
little different so on most charity
she's been playing games we're raising
over it was a real swell on that yeah we
playing games doing money for charities
today playing games raising money for
charity so I thought today what we do is
do something a little bit more challenge
based to but that for you three I'm just
controlling I am just I am the cipher
you you will I will I will do it so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna do
something called the three little Sims
challenge which is good thing a lot of
sim youtubers do it actually let me get
up the credit for who invented it it was
Sethi and addict 1220 are those
usernames some from somewhere it's been
going since the sims 3 but basically
what you do is you have a lot with three
little houses on and to have three sims
and the deal is I can only control one
simpered day and you let the other two
just do whatever they want you kind of
see what scrapes they get into so I'm
gonna give each of you
the sin and we're gonna follow that
their lives and you know hopefully try
and make them excel and money get into
relationships there is a pool that
all-nighters so don't worry okay grand
no doubt
I've pre-made two Sims I've also
decorated the houses Eric look at your
email oh no it sounds like this it
something it pops down and then comes
back it you're trying to prank yeah oh
there yeah there we go
boom was i okay so we each controls sim
yeah so off the bat before we get into
creative Sam we are raising money for
two very good causes links are on the
screen right now so black lives matter
Victor ly / GS - BLM and Direct Relief
who are giving frontline healthcare
workers who battling the covert 19 pond
emic they're giving them protective
clothing and support so beta ly / GS -
kovat tan you're gonna be reading out
donations as we go through yeah I will
be doing that also you can go to store
gamespot.com
where we have a nice range of
merchandise including a skate deck see
Lucy wearing it and I'd be like Oh
where'd you buy that from and she'd be
like its GameSpot its G by Games
all proceeds from this I believe until
the end of August and go 50-50 split
between Direct Relief and black lives
matter so it's all high-quality stuff
I've got that post that most of us have
that post it called yeah we have where
in those posters so you could figure out
which game
is there and who were they're up to it
looks like royal Tenenbaums Anderson
poster all right shall we yeah let's do
it
I should warn you I feel like I've
played a lot of Sims mostly for content
and I will do hours and hours and
accomplish absolutely nothing so yeah
just trying to set set the bar you know
where it needs to be set so about five
minutes before we started I did say
should we get wizards in but I don't
know okay that's the same sins well
that's like Katy Perry's in there
somewhere I don't know how to find her
does not know he's a wizard yet he or
she today you're saying delivered by a
salamander but there's no post on
Sundays so oh oh shoot you're right but
now um do we want
I mean festival do we want to have a
male a female sim can you just randomize
everything like randomize you call
aspects of everything ran Darian
Stratton great name
straws okay male or female sim or
non-binary there's very cool things
about it for sure what what do we won so
I've made a male and a female already so
that's going on I just saw where you can
choose whether this sim can get pregnant
or get others pregnant that's just weird
I mean I guess it makes sense right yeah
if you can pick all of the all of the
you know gender aspect I mean yeah I'm
just thinking it's like a weird thing
it's not the kind of menu you know you
talk about the accessibility options of
last of us to the accessibility of
getting one or not one pregnant is
interesting okay so we've got male
female did you say we could do
non-binary well I don't think the Sims
uses pronouns Comus nada or como Linda
right right okay you know that could be
true I like I the only Simlish I
remember is salsa mm-hmm you make a
child no no no
they can adult young adult
what's the slider it goes from candy to
trumpet we've got a have a kid surely
like a child just living life on it's
like toddlers iPod Lee yes please okay
so a toddlers are only sweet yeah but
this toddler is just trying to behave
like an adult
yeah no one no one says anything it's
like it's a Richie Rich type scenario
and the house and everything okay are we
happy with Darien Stratton let's let's
shuffle that first name yeah reshuffle
that name Derek I love the name keep
shuffling let's keep going let's do a
straw gay I was gonna say let's pick a
number and then Lucy shuffles to that
number and libraries we have 49 hop star
yeah okay so male or female I think this
is just appearance so male or female I
like I like I'd like that I like yeah
the pink yeah so what traits can we get
a kid a balloon
I don't yeah yeah clingy and I can't
well it's because there's a child they
don't have a lot of you're not you know
offense but you're not that dynamic
sorry to hold the children toddlers
watching the stream I mean this baby is
already more stylish than I could
possibly be so okay so you want to just
randomize yeah random let's pick a
number I'm gonna say 98 for maybe
ten okay ten okay
three I just want to say I read like
that one
yeah it's really good five six seven no
that sucks
cool sunglasses yeah give the kid some
glue yeah nice drunk all the time
sunglass hey you got their eyes polished
in a prison
what kind of formal baby where are we
talking here you know when you go for an
interview or something that's a good
look if you're gonna say you're gonna go
out you're meeting with the CEO you got
your yellow shirt on okay these are just
like the so this is different outfit
yeah this is formal wear it's a very
small baby
party time oh nice hat
how does the baby look Nike and three at
the same time
I like that papaya wait no it has to be
this yeah when were yeah that's about
right like it and a panda top yeah panda
okay all right this baby yeah hang over
babe
hang on baby okay so are we happy with
Liam I love Liam
I'd die for them Liam doesn't really
have many many traits yeah but you know
what
life's a blank canvas mm-hmm Jonathan
Strickland in the chat says pretending
this baby is in a actual interview so it
says here on your CV that you are a
toddler the way innovation what of it if
we accidentally made a prequel to boss
baby yeah we have
just saw that message that said babies
aren't allowed to own houses which i
think is number one a little
discriminatory but number two does that
mean we have to make an adult or would
it be easier to just age up Liam I'm
attached to Liam I'm not gonna lie okay
wait I think can I be a teen okay so we
could have teen Liam from this yeah what
are the steps there okay yeah okay
that's fine that's fine it's like the
kid no you don't know what I mean maybe
it's just the style choices there that's
I don't like Old Lace there's no age
that's that's humanity in a nutshell you
can go from this is adorable baby it's
kind of a what the hell adult and then
you just go gray from there Liam what
happened
what is this warm voice okay hang on oh
that's nice where do you think where
would you say my voice lands between
candy and trumpet supposed to be like
Charlie Brown exactly yeah I'm halfway
between Bell and campfire about right
there yeah that's where people say my
voice is often do we want to keep Liam
on till we wanna do we want to randomize
I stuck with it let's look let's just
keep Liam I mean we yeah let's just keep
Liam I know we're not happy about it but
since is all about change right you're
not supposed to yeah and content with
the way you are so just have to accept
what your child is mm-hmm
wait and that knew that what that is is
camo socks all the way up to your nest
oh I didn't dominate the flip-flops yeah
I didn't realize they were flip-flops
and socks Oh a swagger
if you walk if he just looks like he's
kind of high yeah yeah I mean gonna get
home that's a very Liam anything I'm
gonna say sleepy no sorry sluggish
sluggish or bouncy I don't see you felt
right
yeah bouncy bouncy is a good one bouncy
second from the bottom I think it was oh
yeah it's like that so that's it to
someone who used to be a baby yeah it's
definitely it's the walk of someone with
confidence that shouldn't have it oh yes
yeah unearned which i think is Liam yeah
yeah yeah yeah all right
what does Liam want I think Liam wants
to be popular but isn't popular we can
have party animal it was meets median oh
wow I also like that they said joke star
as though the word comedian is like
copyright yeah um
nature what's that one mmm-hmm just
wants to go fishing ocean ocean so oh
that must mean DLC right so make sure
animal what's your animal sound like a
Steve Irwin type just a friend of the
animal tank at all deviants what we
going to be be ins yeah no friend of the
animals public anyone like enemy for
mischief sheep of mischief not just any
mischief no they work for you okay I
love the idea of Liam being a Public
Enemy though it's like Tyler Durden I
I'm good I'm good for whatever or
whatever we want Public Enemy sounds fun
look enemy okay yeah do we want to
randomize these yeah it's random again
so he wants to be erratic erratic and
materialistic oh we really know how to
raise him yeah are we happy with this I
feel like we're stuck with this outfit
choice yeah yeah
what one of the options does he have so
we came the Fox City back house is a
child actually or like an evolution of
the park city oh he's like reverse
punisher oh this one that's kind of cool
thank you so much you know what Sheena I
don't remember find that DLC but okay I
like it
uh are we happy with the cargo shorts I
mean isn't everybody
I thought cargo shorts across the board
were considered acceptable am i right
higher maybe higher like oh I kind of
like that interesting choice Liam always
felt most college boys in there in there
when their bedtime attire when they were
wearing their yellow shirt and then just
their underwear okay we have people with
this for a date I'm good to me yeah yeah
okay Richie Rich formal okay about this
week it's the casino yeah
athletic rob the casino it's just a
different kind of cargo shorts I'm
starting to learn something here
how cargo chores mm-hmm he's better
dressed to sleep the news he goes to
sleep in a suit I'm sure the printed
v-neck that one the yellow one yes it's
pretty cool hmm it looks right oh that's
that's terrible
all of that is yeah that's all we can do
though okay each tire I'm not I'm gonna
say the rainbow the rainbow tank is
pretty cool yeah I like it I like it and
it's tucked into the swim trunks okay
hot weather wear scarf the scarf in the
bottle oh yeah yeah okay back packing
the depo gap year yeah the default
outfit seems like is arguably Liam's
worst look this imagine if he was that
stylish I don't know who doesn't know
purple coat oh yeah yeah I won the
Grindelwald they come away old weather
liam is a fashionista
okay it's like it's like when the nerdy
nerdy person in the movie takes off
their glasses and it turns out they're
very attractive yeah when the cold when
the snow comes people go oh my gosh Liam
had no idea I feel that it is perfect
for this this character I would never be
caught dead in it but all right let's do
it okay so this is the game we just
click on outfits let's go now we're
talking I like this wait hang on
all right great hat yes golf balls and
of course a yeah look at that yeah did
you call it a wrestling hat that's crazy
oh bike helmet
I think Mike Hellmuth their little
beanie oh yeah I like I mean I like all
these it's ready for anything
mm-hmm like falling off a bike I mean I
was ready for most things except for one
time you know I wasn't ready for a life
saver should we move him in yeah yeah
yeah let's go Liam's friend while
they're moving in we should remind
people that they can donate to the two
causes that were supporting firstly
black lives matter Victoria Falls last
year's - BLM and indirect relief don't
know why for /gs - Kovach please donate
generously if you can all proceeds go
directly to those fundraising causes
okay so wait where'd he go areas okay
currently not in world no - not in well
put her into the lemon who's that
mysterious you know this is these other
two these are all that live on that
property all right we're gonna we're
gonna learn about he just paid the lemon
family $20,000 hey wanna miss a meal in
in don't wanted red looks like a jojo's
bizarre adventure character yeah
what zeppeli yeah okay so again the
house Liam damu Damodar everyone you get
to pick which Sims member you wouldn't
like me to play you're about to be a
custody battle over Liam I know yeah
so it must be the Sims because one
character is already upset well
admittedly the Sims full gallery is
fantastic and I just downloaded these
but I decorated them myself
okay got it by using the simple tool
because I'm not you know inclined to be
good at decorating so house number one
mhm
we've gone for kind of like a little
modern so gone for like a more of a
modern feel very clean lines teleporter
over there this house is built for a
gamer
we've got top-of-the-line computer we
have it's a gaming like do you remember
when uh oculus first came out and they
had those treadmills mm-hmm that's what
this is I was they say it looks like a
menace er what was it was that was the
genesis thing that you could play Mortal
Kombat with by punching and different oh
yeah never trouble you remember yeah let
us know we've got a nice little bathroom
[Music]
nice very good
outside of didn't mean to do that but
we've got a little grill and a pool so
all of the backyards are connected game
is paradise
in house number one Oh a darker palette
here this one is more of a natural this
remember this household shops at Whole
Foods you know yeah for sure
big Pinterest fans every house has a
laptop by the way so Sims can kind of
like do whatever they want this house
though is built for someone who would
like a cat so we've got cat immunities
entry literary so they don't have a cat
yet they just have cat accessories okay
a little weird cat and cat accessories
yes I couldn't I couldn't build them put
the cat and then just a very plain
bedroom and I forgot to put the window
in but you know what you don't need it
don't need it
you want to be dark at least likes when
it's dark you don't probably prefer no
windows in the bedroom to just sleep in
the dark he's lying like a like a
vampire
sleep buddy mentioned that James okay
Coolio's you know we've got like a
little bird skull in the kitchen we've
got a nice Shea's long we have a an
organ organ don't worry we've also got a
little tablet if you wanna play okay
great on the games and coffin to sleep
in perfect this seems like a Liam this
is 100 percent Liam's place for sure
well should we shall we meet the other
contestants and then we get to pick
what's under that glass yeah this is
this is a relic of almost like a
vultures skull Oh No yeah looks like
like an old-timey doctor doctor mask so
some people have spices in the kitchen
this house has a little skull got it
great you got God since waking you're so
close to stuff this is a well done away
from all right these are three houses
okay let's meet our contestants number
one this is this is Chelsea Hawkins I
think okay she she loves animals mm-hmm
and she would like to be friends with
animals water her other traits day she
loves cats she likes going outdoors
she's a bit of a good finger find a cat
but yet her whole life is a could we
take a look at her bladder could we see
what her bladder looks like okay all
right a lot of levels in 2/3 2/3 okay
got it is all the litter box yeah tells
you a lot about a person she's very
under socialized right now though
the McCallion yeah we know what about
Liam let y'all know Liam we don't see
much and then we've got Reese lemon who
is a vampire okay well I'm gonna call
him separately from now on yeah eppley
so he what he would like to become a
master vampire okay he's definitely a
gamer for sure I was gonna say he's for
sure the gamer
yeah put in the game work or do you
think maybe someday he'd want a cat
there's a chance he may want a cat well
I don't know if he can um be around cats
because surely they would be like yeah
but he loves to be around a webcam yeah
I just hate pigeon holding people into
boxes you know like some people may be
vampires but they don't necessarily want
to be vampires so he's he's unhappy
because he's obviously out in the Sun
his traits are that he's evil he's
hot-headed good but he's also a genius
so that sounds like extreme who wants
who Reese all right turn around okay
well it was just Tam's birthday so I
feel like he should get to decide first
yeah yeah oh you go ahead and pick first
one zeppeli nice good choice so you want
anyone Reese that's illegal about his
home on he's just swearing yes the
street let's go they're already taken
they're trying to take their bombs Wow
okay so she's already identified this
okay yeah and Liam is going for the
vampire right now I feel like so who
wants who so Tom you would like
definitely yeah okay so um okay I'm sure
game right
wait I can I can set my then he is
nowhere to go to sleep oh I can
I can stop them locked up everyone
everyone but Rhys also they can't even
visit well I won't do that allow access
to employees well how do you do you have
like set their bed or something for them
to know like you're like this is your
bed so one next to the big window a sign
oh yeah if you want oh it looks looks
like he's already got it
looks like they've already claimed
before we even started this that's wild
but it's also against the challenge that
we are actually a.m. mm-hmm
controlling more than one so okay Tam
you've got him Elise James take your
pick
go ahead at least you can pick next
don't take Kat
Chelsea Chelsea Hawkins you want Chelsea
yeah
no Liam then I'll take Liam I thought
all right thought you may want Liam I
mean all day and happy to help
I'm just just I'm like the old Greek
gods hanging up in Olympus messing
around probably turning into an ego and
having sex with Liam I'm just gonna get
rid of those trees cuz they're in my way
I'm sorry
nature it's okay okay who wouldn't say
who wants to go first you have to
control a day in the life okay well like
we should be Liam so I'll go first we'll
do day one is Liam day one is lame okay
so he wants a life of crime life of
crime means he disliked performed 10
mean or mischievous interactions okay
oh he is at school though he is at
school hasn't started his homework how
does he not alright because he's a
teenager
oh can he get a part-time job
Liam huh yeah well big same sorry great
on the emotional control he can buy a
vet clinic though oh okay
interesting possible romance the Chelsea
well it would be to break her heart
okay so let's just get in there what are
is he he needs some things he what is
we picked up the iPad immediately has
gone to play block tap so I want to
figure out a way to really aggravate
Liam's neighbors that's kind of what I
want to do so maybe can we call them and
ask them to come over and then ignore
them the whole time they're there
something you know something mischievous
something Liam would do so do we want to
do that with these guys oh yeah okay and
he's gaming too yeah okay what can we do
we could oh maybe so sis caregiver can
be mean it can be mischievous I wonder
if there's something Liam could do to
Chelsea's house while she is swimming
prank some sort of prank is there is
there a can can Liam get in there and
like chocolate cake Liam's favorite meal
I think it was it was their dead bread
their pan de muerto yeah the reason
we're dead bread do the Goodman
vegetarians vegetarian safe yeah
vegetable dumplings okay I don't think I
can can I cook that cuz he's already
cooked in something else use fresh
ingredients
Jesus Simmons has changed so much since
I was so do you want do you want to make
a dead bread or do we want to make more
whatever was going before I think it was
a chocolate cake right it was fine it's
like chocolate cake is more menacing
it's gonna also use more pots and more
pans yeah ultimately leave a bigger mess
look a zeppole those off in the corner
just playing games gaming hard so happy
yeah when we started eppley was so upset
no where you going
maybe he's just nicking ingredients to
make pretty miss you yes wait is he
trying with oh she's she's coming up at
a chat oh great
Chelsea Christ okay
making a cake here I'm making using your
ingredients mm-hmm Reese's got the video
yes he doesn't know what he's doing
alright then you pop that in the oven
that's the hey I was gonna be this
button sort of kept to herself no no
she's crazy straight you get bikini into
the pool Cakes done don't offer any cake
Reese's coming do we want to be mean to
Chelsea like mmm-hmm we probably should
be should we should we set her as the
primary caregiver and then just be a
complete jerk I just worried that she's
gonna be over all the time we're all
going to lose it I didn't eat any cake
by the way made a mess someone in chat
says you gave your Sims freewill big
mistake
as usual Liam's the third wheel just
talking about trash whoa whoa whoa
what's this all about the gaming chair
gamer it's not set to support her lumbar
what can we do we can obsess about
favorite celebrity oh we can anybody
touch him oh so he's like your surrogate
complain about parents complain about
parents I don't know where they are mean
yeah mock uncool adult yeah yeah you
should do that yes oh my gosh no the
birds going on
oh yeah my house Oh empathise gone
I've got no empathy for that go sit on
the couch talk drink about your popcorn
nap do a nap on them well I mean it's 20
past 10:00 at night he might actually
fall asleep no he is he is going to
sleep nice man one one of these Lud's
gonna sleep and what couch the other
ones playing my games the books I have
like weird little things in him so Reese
has this Amazon Alexa oh okay that was
terrifying because my Alexa just
activated cuz my package just got
delivered and I don't well the timing of
that was very strange
she has Oh who's this joining me this
guy yeah sure what kind of introduction
a rude one chief of mischief get up
who's visitors do you have to invite
vampires in for them to be able to enter
in the sex Wow dad's name is Stroud
young adult life how long has he been a
young adult names like hey did you want
to go inside her house yeah go ahead
slowly fine oh he's lacking in manners
now and where are you going yeah see he
run a by what is he doing creep it's for
the coffin he's gonna know he's gonna go
play games oh my god obsessed he the
cake I don't think he eats cake
conversation is going on a lot longer
than I thought it would have for someone
again
monster noise Oh a trick with hand
buzzer trick with hand buzzer yeah
bench we knew Sh good anyway it's really
nice meeting you
it's an unpleasant conversation don't L
can ask him buzz vampire history sure
silly
I've never met a vampire before so
you're not open legend vampire history
shove slap him silly show-off outfit
insults you like the outfit shows off
itself yeah
lie about bad plasma oh yeah that's
definitely something that vampires hate
talking about chest of drawers
definitely must be furious
I'm the vampire just playing bejeweled
or whatever on that iPad names gonna try
and go to bed soon okay that's one way
to end a car that's like an Irish
goodbye she sent him to bed yeah I guess
so yeah read epitaph alright yeah if I
recall there's a cemetery in the back
there's those we're his parents
Oh Barry can't wait to see you one weird
thing to put on there all right come on
mate see all we do in pay my offense
mm-hmm don't worry to have some
chocolate cake if you want anyway good
night fresh
can he get in oh he can go on I don't
like his menacing laughing mmm-hmm
right he's definitely just adding loads
of unsavory sites as bookmarks oh yeah
it's a new day technically so should we
move over to Reese that seems like a
natural progression yeah that parlez
we're already in the house that we want
to make mischief in you want to become a
master vampire vampires do oh yeah some
dark meditation let's go oh man I'm
curious to see what that show dark form
is come back later
did you just throw that on the floor
okay you'd found the trash oh yes I
thought he was gonna do an air bicycle
what he's just gaining vampire points
yes there's a meter on the left going up
that's just vampire points let's go path
to vampire
oh he's energized and now he wants to
just look at some art on the wall
classic vampire behavior can he murder
like what is a man we can go see if he
can do anything
- maybe Chelsea vampiric he can wake her
up oh can he like do weird oh wait
there's a vampire family apparently this
guy never left
hold on he's he can't actually go in
there he's not been invited no he is his
household so I think he can okay what
the hell
oh he teleported we know what but he
teleported in vampire beef we need to
get this guy out rude introduction I'm
the only vampire in this block
ignoring it I can't introducing care
that you exist okay all right everyone
using my computer request request
training there we go
I apologize I didn't realize you were so
informed on the vampire arts would you
train me tell me about my a my home on
vampire APM needs to go up he's into
that all right teach me show me a ways
bye-bye on a motorcycle I should fight
yeah
what does look like that he stole my
power you have three power points it
says can we turn it to a bat that's tiny
to about okay so detect personality
platformer cast hallucination eternally
welcome or occult student I'm just gonna
say a vampire bat it seems like the
small thing to do here mmm-hmm you got
one more point allusions or
hallucinations or whatever that one is
yeah there we go yes
teach me senpai what is going teach me
and then get out my house yeah vampires
do they just stand in the room and just
talk about things I can do very easily
by God vampire
Tim I'm not gonna tell you what to do
but the worst thing you could ever do to
another vampire as the vampire is
insulting buying sighs that's nice oh no
baby go he's got I mean he might've just
teleported into some other villain he
said oh no wait is he around while we're
figuring out where this lads gone just a
reminder that you can donate to black
lives matter and also Cove aid relief
efforts in partnership with Direct
Relief the links are on the screen and
Ritchie is putting them in chat
hopefully and they're also below the
video please donate generously if you
can be massively massively helpful yeah
we've had a fourteen dollars donation
$14 in eleven cents from no Asik pal who
is one of the MVPs of our charity
efforts just keeps showing up and then
Evan avoidin gave $100
black lives matter Thank You Evan um we
can imply that his mother was Alam your
boy no can we do the don't see it
there's two vampires out in the town you
know having like two vampires - vampires
generally one big Fang sizes or small
Fang sizes he keeps vanishing away so
it's like almost anything else you know
the assumption is that a vampire would
want a bigger Fang size because writing
implication but the truth is the matter
is that all victims of vampire bites
don't really care it's more about it's
more about the biting technique than it
is about the size I'd also say as a
vampire
are you a grower like do you have those
incisors that when you here to feed do
they elongate yeah you know I honestly
it's not about the size of the fangs is
how you use them exactly that's true
here we go disable autonomy for selected
sim there we go oh so now they have to
do what you want so the ones that we
control have to do what we want but the
ones who aren't um have to yeah Oh time
you can fly places as a bat mm-hmm let's
go she's awake now we can try and do
some vampire mischief yeah let's do that
can we just fly she's on the front in
front of her and then appear as a bat
yeah yeah why she's in toilet oh my get
the demons out where is he oh he
appeared is a vet care one bit okay
compel for a small drink a deep drink
we'll ask the permission also permission
is Apple Empire yeah excuse me may I
drink your plasma
oh hi there didn't see their I mean no
next time you won't ask I think this is
his milestone now when this is you make
a vampire pond yeah a vampire own keep
busy by looking for the next victim okay
Wow yeah his jokes are no Seurat too
much to drink here I think you have to
compare unpleasant conversation oh lads
: he's just saying stay out of the Sun
he said he sent you plasma packs over
the phone future is now oh yeah that's
kept me out of the sunlight wait you
want to try doing the drink yeah still
how would i chat there we go
uh-huh green boy that's interesting his
dark form it's Edward Cullen small drink
that's nice more drink my man tumbler
yeah oh my god damn why do you want to
go maybe game inside which house so
Liam's house okay three feet no I know I
want him to use bat form in the laziest
possible can we came to wake Liam up by
looking inside the coffee oh I think
Liam's awake no he's not he's in there
he's very sound sleeper
it's air time he actually died about
three and a half just just sleeping that
you climb in with him maybe it's gonna
be quite a surprise he seems in there oh
no he's gonna go to school though can
you engrave his epitaph on there while
he's in there
Liam's in here your time will come Liam
thanks for the memory thanks for nothing
oh thanks for nothing is good we would
thanks for nothing I think I can only
say one alright just paragraphs upon
paragraphs yeah and thanks no it's
lustre when the secondary sentiment see
what it
why is he embarrassed you walked in on
something you were never meant to see
what what do we say who did he see it
was that hurt
yeah that was an hours against ages ago
we've drank blood since yeah it's like
I've been inside you we can't wake up
Liam all right well he's got school so
he's gonna have to deal with that
himself because we control him Oh
lacking in vampire energy
time for bed I think oh boy we can do
that yeah that's to meditate but let's
meditate in front of Kelsey try that
again absolutely incontinent five times
a day yeah goodbye really Chelsea come
back to my house
use my computer again you just meditate
mirror it gets too bright in front of
her to be gross absolutely tiny gross
you've done it you've accomplished it
yeah I'm a fine vampire Rhys is evil
evil sins become happy from the misery
of others
oh she smelled your fart doc medication
always move as a bat I've turned on Oh
Liam is off to school now that's good
are you Liam cause I missed you boy
you're out there mmm okay so that's how
you get your your bad points back while
we're getting the bat points back shot
Joseph Keola Jonah who donate $25
towards manna and Thank You Joseph so is
this the sims way of making it so now
your Sims don't have to sleep they're
like oh well people want to do stuff at
night and they seems always gonna sleep
so we'll just make vampires that are up
all the time but just have to meditate
I guess it also helps to this challenge
because it means you're not really
waiting for anyone to sleep
mm-hmm I just think there's a natural
cross section between liking the Sims
and liking vampires I think we should he
still needs to recover energy right my
boo I've put him to bed and switching
all right well no sleep yeah go to bed
yeah over there as a bat probably she
just slept under the bed yeah go alright
I my kids trying to move on to Chelsea
who is having a bad time a bad time oh
she's cleaning up the cake somewhere
Liam's like to school here just go yeah
so um she must be a friend of the
animals
mm-hmm-hmm we could buy a vet clinic
lure the animals to us yes that seems
like a really roundabout way to get a
cab
you can just adopt one we've got all the
things we can give a dog - I think I
like the I will get the dog again I
think I think we should challenge
Chelsea she's a cat person she wants the
cat we get her the dog get her I put her
out of her comfort zone yeah we say you
know why don't you gotta earn the cat
you deal with the dog first ordered
garlic seeds all right research where is
it social I can never find anything in
the sims volunteers find a job by vet
clinic yeah take photo it's a Sunday
like adopt a game oh it's not order no
web blog about feelings
[Music]
career entire household maybe household
household yeah
just adopt a dog oh is that a child is
the cost of adopting a child only five
times the cost of adopting a dog yep all
right welcome to the neighborhood oh
okay wait oh my god Toki Brandis kind of
weird-looking yeah Brandi looks like
pure purebred gone wrong
I'm sorry Brandi Tanner looks very very
menacing yeah Toki you're gonna need one
that isn't neutered she's yeah what we
clear rules yeah
probably if you're a domination Tokyo
the same animal yes yeah well heavier
ones cute - Toki maybe Tokyo Chucky okay
what kind of animal what kind of dog
read was that looks like a fox um when
you adopt them do they just run into
your household Network I don't know Oh
Welcome Wagon I was hoping I just like
spring out of the cupboard oh no that's
because no it's here
oh wow wow it's it's a tiny little fox
ah eppley is gonna drink that Fox's
blood a friendliest introduction gosh
maybe cautious cuz she's a cat woman oh
I guess because you haven't adopted yet
they're gonna wait see if it actually
works out this emit you can do in real
life you just have people bring you
animals play with the animals and then
right after the fact that you don't want
them or not yeah how's he doing
Richie in chat said Tanner was straight
up a hyena um so yeah you can choose to
adopt or you can do some training you
mean to it I mean at least it's your
choice I think be training
would be the wise decision see if we're
compatible okay which one can do sit or
lie down speak or a real speak this oh
this is the guy who has like five cats
in my neighborhood okay that's a sadness
in her though this still isn't a cat no
so yeah again it's about challenging her
expectations it did not expect the dogs
voice to sound like that I think they
needed to translate dog sounds into
Simlish - this is like wah wah wah wah
who are these people that I just hanging
around outside
what do we want to do with training go
for jog let's do the jog yeah this is
adoption agents like you get ahead take
the dog or what you're just going for a
jog you've taught it how to do this
barking now yeah change into a little
jogging attire oh oh wow look at that
alright you stay here bud we'll be back
see ya
thanks for the dog talk do you like one
adoptee or not oh all right I do thank
man Wow way faster Wow they're burnt
that was it
they're burnt oh I did I did put a
little Park in so I wonder if they do
she - is that from this angle
looks like squirrel yeah she's like a
hundred percent Nick but wouldn't it be
better if she was running with her cat
wow that's cute this dog is gonna be
like I pass don't want to be a doctor
thank you
it's too much effort she dragged my ass
around this park struggling desperately
trying to keep up
cheerful decor from the toilet oh you've
got lucky
oh is that cause you're energized yeah
question is has she earned a cat yeah I
don't know maybe a well like I like what
you are you were coming from the angle
of maybe she needs to step out of her
comfort zone maybe a cat isn't what she
needs it's what she thinks she needs a
great time with this dog although she is
sweaty as hell
Wow she crossed the road and just was
like nah I know don't have any me sucks
so like this tropical neighborhood
reminds me of Celesteville from Babar
huh seems I love you but like Jesus
Christ
if I hit track please making it on track
oh she's filthy Wow
we're so far from home I wish we could
just vampire it back
I left the dog are you left wait is he
oh that's not the guy no that's just the
dog she got tired of the dog company if
you abandon the dog I guess it didn't
work out huh I mean so maybe not the
best sign maybe not the most responsible
owner is
look what you want to do do you wanna
adopt the dog do you want to have a
shower you can't pass on the dog oh my
gosh really all that it's not him it's
us that be is massive holy [ __ ]
can we adopt that be what's our
relationship like with this dog
it's very antagonistic look they're not
even on speaking terms
relationships mm-hmm pets often feel
strongly about someone but this pet
doesn't seem to feel much of anything
Wow you know some of these this foxier
breeds like Sheba's and stuff they're
fairly independent yeah for sure
like a cat would be so that I guess this
is just a good sampling yeah hmm
do you want to have a shower or oh yeah
I've got a nice bath yeah I guess we
should take a bath should you take a
bowl say that you don't want the dog
anymore you just come with the dog
wander around the neighborhood dog I
don't know here is is he gonna take a
dog stop get in there oh I guess he just
found the dog wandering the streets and
I see my canine is he's going elsewhere
she knows she's oh oh that's a cloak of
honey attack Bruce Lee Bruce Lee
portrait that you have in there oh no
it's just sometimes terrifying well
thanks you can download some mods if you
really want to see everything not the
boss the boss himself you let's go ahead
and get those mods loaded up yeah let's
change a change of this extreme no need
to make room on the refrigerator his
work is merely satisfactory
[Music]
that's my classic Liam oh here he is
to make cake I've got an idea here with
my hands just she's feeling playful
after bath there's a hint of sadness
there though she knows and doesn't end
with crying she's hungry
she's tired it's 4 p.m. someone's just
ena chips I always forget that Sims
essentially have like the energy levels
of like 80 year old you know adults
they're like it's 4 o'clock I am
exhausted I've gotta sleep my house is
he going to his house he's gonna go play
some games we have to control his do you
want her to make a little she could make
like a portion size that Liam could eat
as well that'd be great well the dead
bread yeah oh yeah dead bread oh wait
wait come on single-serving
oh no do you want some for Liam - oh
that's ok he's he's full on chips fend
for himself
yeah yeah she's gonna want to make all
this bread for everyone I'm just gonna
take it and not thank her for it do we
get a cat now I mean she's so tired I
feel like she definitely didn't instill
confidence and mm-hm didn't have enough
counter space is that what this is it
feels like it feels like oh maybe but I
mean
let's try that Liam was able to make
know if he made it any other room I
think this is just this is the situation
they've arranged for themselves were
they good they always go to her fridge
you didn't make it at Liam's Wow only it
was that easy yeah hey now it's ready
Three's Company situation we got $10
donation from Matt Hawking thank you
Matt also Matt thank you for your was it
was it Matt who did the Photoshop yeah
yes and he also like um we did trivia
yesterday and I was so bad that I was
basically just saying they in silence
for most of it and he gave a $10
donation with the message happy birthday
I'm glad you were able to take the day
off
wow did Jack win the trivia I did nice
it was named X between Jack and general
he was good he was great and he kept
saying every time there was a film that
was filmed in Austin he would mmm-hmm
he wouldn't know it and he was gonna say
for bonus points but Jesse did not nice
what's Jack's history who didn't he work
with mando's mm-hmm I mean he worked in
LA for a little while and that in the
entertainment industry
I think he went back I don't know I
don't know Jack's life what's going on
with Liam I'm someone I know I feel like
I'm old enough now that I should be
allowed to go where anywhere I want to
do whatever I want can you treat me like
an adult please I can the only response
is you'll always be my baby we related
to him what I think so confused I think
yes I don't know he's looking in the
mirror I also like that this is coming
from someone who's wearing like a hoodie
like and no pants and then a bicycle
helmet at all times but sure you're an
adult now Liam congratulations
Chelsea has advised Liam affecting his
character values his empathy is
increased with his responsibility his D
creams love it hmm sorry Chelsea's mom
wait I can I can check it's kind of just
like the Adobe's honest people that came
and stood on the patio yeah yeah um
Chelsea's genealogy she's not related
just her whoa whoa what's happened there
I mean he's showering it's what you
gotta do right technically is this how
his house thing Chelsea admittedly pour
that into the I think there's a bread
pan and now magically appears but I like
that old timey stove yeah it looks
really cool it's very Liam she actually
has the same stove I'm same fridge she
chooses not to use it
Oh Jim as your bread [ __ ] she's tired
grab yourself grab yourself us dead
bread for the road we're so comfortable
I set a table
I like that table cause it's the kind of
table where someone's go may you pass
the salt yeah I guess and you have to
get up and hand it over I'll just need
to pee okay right on the toilet I don't
think they can do that you know it's
such a shame there's so many things
about the Sims or if you could just do
the multitasking that you know yeah you
or I would do in real life eating your
dead bread on the toilet you can get so
much more accomplished yeah she crying
into this bread okay sorry she feels
playful now oh no hang on
oh it was delicious okay and she why was
she crying oh she maybe it was like it
was like she's enjoying it it's like
that time Lucy you go
then almost cried like that was the last
day of Gamescom and they kept bringing
all the food and they kept walking past
us and there was a point where they put
a pizza down and I just made a noise I
grabbed a plate at left is he doing the
dishes
Oh clean this for you ha ha okay all
right well she should probably pee and
go to bed and then I think making him do
bat foam everywhere you never expected
to see me I'm just standing in the
bushes watching because I'm an adult now
[Laughter]
that made me cry all right truce swap
over to Liam oh sure yeah what time is
it how much time is left it's like a pee
but I was thinking that maybe Liam could
become a wizard oh yeah absolutely
let's get him some ice games with food
and
how does he become a wizard now I am
playing brick block so whatever maybe I
need to buy him some wizard stuff Oh
careful what you wish for I'm getting
spooky music so yeah yeah never
definitely having spooky music filter
items okay oh wait maybe it's in here
oh there's potion right is that a
cauldron okay oh that's pretty big um
can you put it in the back maybe I gotta
spit it out here okay I mean what about
a spooky bookcase
sure hmm be a great way to learn okay
time I dunno ooh he's cute sure little
little thing time do you wanna can you
google what I need to do Magic Castle
and in Hollywood what you want me to
Google how to make some noises oh the
razzle-dazzle gate yeah that
razzle-dazzle okay maybe maybe there's
just like a wizard attribute if what you
can't clean up that one but he go oh
he's has he gone to mop up he has the
cleanest vampire blood he can't help
himself because he's like I want to be
an evil vampire but he can't help his
inner nature which is to be kind and
caring and cleanup plates is this walk
raged it seems like becoming a wizard is
very involved
most things of the sims yeah remember
making magic you just had a wand and you
were done what can I do
cook mac and cheese that's just a oven
just a giant oven um what about read
wizard books oh uh okay broomies which
is fill is a practical spell caster and
all of us studies mischief they've been
friends since childhood but can they
handle living together mm-hmm
someone's job come up with fake names
for fake books that can't be read
witch witch bewitched which which I
profess up to that's poetry
if you like you swing the swings I don't
like it familiar I'm looking at my
collection yeah I feel you want
nonfiction right cuz then you're gonna
read about it
what's his what's his expression they're
down there next to the Aged he's enraged
it's tough being a team sometimes
emotions are hard to keep in check well
it's he's not a teen anymore yeah
apparently until you two go on a trip to
the world of glimmer Brook travel I just
want to go by myself
yeah we'll just go alone okay traveling
somewhere wait let's let's pee before
you take an angry poop yeah yep whoa
because someone's in there bye formed
into a toilet house is a if a vampire we
needs to use the restroom right really
bad but then turns into a bat
is it a human's amount worth of poop oh
that's a good question question or could
you image too with the poop transform to
be the appropriate amount that's on fire
that time that was on fire
[Laughter]
it's about to be even more on fire now
notice he's a little tired he's fine
he's okay so let's let's travel okay oh
maybe once once the travelling happens
that's right yeah yeah travelling gives
you perspective uh so we need to go to
glimmer ville
and then to the wizard school
it's nog warts bah so came a book
mystical Pole that looks like what's
over there by the water
can you go near it and then walk over
there
yes please find the mystical pole you
travel to the realm of magic in order to
become a spell he's complained the poor
sages will only reach this teach the
strongest of spell casters okay that's
definitely Liam drinking off your
transport you into a different world
leave you're stuck in this part of the
area yeah patrons magic pigeons yeah so
we need to get to the mystical pole
isn't a selectable location
how far out can you zoom this is this is
how far I can go wait let me cuz it
looked like there was something in that
waterfall so you need to go to the Wolfe
old western edge of the town by the wall
for oh my gosh well there it is there it
is traveled some magic realm it was easy
yeah the problem is he's he's tired oh
my god nice running the hole screaming
magic I'm gonna be the greatest magician
in the world
oh my god well if only Liam could become
a bat embarrassed
why is he embarrassed privacy violation
Oh cuz he worked it on him dawn what
time to think about why is he on his
phone check your phone tweet oh yes here
we go oh okay magic realm we made it
who's this yeah wizard Liam wait dude
Wow Wow wanted to say hi to ago but Jose
she gone now okay so what is it go in
yeah
now what Tam probably need to be able to
enroll in the school somehow oh we're
gonna make mac and cheese you have to
find the pages him yeah a Gilderoy
Lockhart over here do you want kill her
a lot car or this weird snake boy snake
boy I mean it's not my decision right
you know do they have like Wizarding
houses as well they dude okay what kind
of introduction uh friendly we're trying
to win over the favor of this what's
this person's name
he is a sage of Practical Magic Simeon
silver sweater yeah that's right
wearing a green sweater ask about woohoo
troubled for so many days do reach the
magic Oh what does it mean ask you would
you like to go with me okay so Morgan's
in there too
what yes no is born ready
Liam did not earn this in any way we
should clarify you will need seven
magical moats around four moats and
return to me what thank God you have to
find moats like motes of light
oh there's a little things on the ground
there okay so this is easy thanks I'll
be back in a minute one light on the
ground has Liam have enough energy for
this no look how miserable he looks
doing this can't believe how bad he
wants to be a wizard yeah
he's moping about the entire time like
oh my god come a wizard there's an
indifference to this this whole process
yeah it's like kinda it's like sure it's
like when when you go to a store and
they're like do you have any coupons
you're like no because you're not gonna
use the effort to cut out coupons and
bring them to the store and they go well
we have this digital coupon that we can
process anyway and you'll get the
savings do you want to use it you're
like sure sure
I'll save $2 on that fine and then
they're like you need to sign up this
I'll go help nevermind
they're like well let's do just your
phone number no thank you and then you
just you pay an extra 25 bucks yeah okay
we might be able to still do this before
he falls asleep okay great
we're coming Samia you know
uncomfortable
alright absolute despair in his face
over there oh he's okay he's not he's
not exhausted yet he was focused for
like three seconds yeah and then went
now I'm over this oh look in is that a
toilet under the stairs can I sleep here
tonight
no no get out of it mom can you expense
a cab expensive cab give me money for a
cab
there you go I did it make me magician
now oh nice yeah a spellcaster okay I
mean no offense Elise but Chelsea is
miles behind
zeppeli and Liam in this scenario in
terms of what they got going on in their
lives he's figured out that she's a dog
person no mischief magic because that's
what that's what Liam wants is right so
we don't we don't know it oh very oh how
do you learn them maybe talk to the
there's symbols on there so maybe you
have to talk to the appropriate mischief
magician wait so progress you are stages
for advice okay so by reading books
generously provided around the magic HQ
you can also visit Kosta early to buy
yourself ingredients and a magic wand
however a broomstick for easier travel
Oh wait-wait II buy broomstick I feel
like Liam ally ally wait yeah car
starting to feel a little bit like you
know maybe they're quite all too close
to the Sun with some of this unlicensed
Sims [ __ ] magic stuff knowledge
bragging Ally okay where's Kylie there's
books over there - there's bookshelves I
know you can read the books I think
mischief books search for tomes
eh Oh Lucy searches for Toms please if
you can donate to the two causes that
we're raising money for black lives
matter bit Oly for such years - BLM and
direct relief oh wait o ly for last
year's covered he's fine
he's doing great
and we found do we find a tone so many
tones magic practice magic practice
mischief magic I love it
stop looking at ohms uh-huh practice
this magic right now here we go
oh no want maybe no wonder I think I
want I think I think we went to trying
it oh there we go yeah a wizard of
Liam's prowess doesn't need a wand
nothing's really going on with his
mischief yeah it's new its new it's uh
is he trying to cast on a master spell
cast it - yes most looms game here solar
flare yeah what's the planetarium a
jewel okay cuz cuz so Simeon is a
practical magic sage you would have to
find someone who's a mischief magic sage
and then ask them what to do or we can
just go get a watt or a broom go to the
store and buy a broom so is the store
here it's in a place called what was the
court again something alley yeah we
travel then tap twister alley how do you
cost as early in in in glimmer Brook
here okay charm family yeah
is it maybe it is but in this in the
fantasy world like maybe that's not a
map thing maybe it's like a location in
the world wait oh go to Julie there's
another one oh yeah I came in oh there's
got me like a town area shorty
sit around forever they know how to do
it they're gonna put portals to where
you need to go this way this is the last
time you'll ever have to walk Liam once
you get there you get a broom you'll be
on your way I'm just gonna buy you a
bunch of stuff and then yeah what can we
can we've got race you could turn into a
bat what can Chelsea turn into where is
he oh okay very upset by that everything
a ghost
mm by ones Thomson Oh
let's buy familiar mm-hmm or at least
see what that's what okay I count
familiar who make Josi jealous all right
James we're gonna buy let's see well
bone wand was my nickname in high school
how much money we got plenty of money or
good times let's go down let's see a
little bit what other options we got so
we got a bone wand um despite this this
is a familiar a mysterious and Silent
One this is a frightening one mm-hmm a
bat mm-hmm
that theme going can we get a the bat
familiar and then Oh what was that last
one at the bottom one did this Silvia oh
that looks like a good rod yeah I want
that I want that one
okay weird sorry Liam wants that one can
raise people from the dead we can Oh
instantly incinerate people perfect I'm
just gonna get it now that way here all
right without looking at the time any of
you what time do you currently think is
like in real life real life
about 7:00 p.m. I was lost all meanings
good
well I think we've fallen into the same
trap it's almost 2 o'clock
really yes 148 there's a mop the magic
ball a classic wood broom know that
magic mop all right 50 bucks yeah it's a
steal
really I'm flashing forward to some
hijinks where zeppeli tries to clean the
floor with his mop but accidentally uses
the magic mop oh no always these brooms
and always into the concrete I'm a spell
for fixing a shattered nose I'm just
gonna let him sleep for a little he's
almost a concussion well that's why he's
wearing his helmet
all right all right
can he broom them who's flying with him
the concrete no stop trying with him I
want you to use your broom Oh a tragic
life Liam's back I know maybe to go home
he uses it maybe for bigger distances
isn't that maybe it's not like the bat
where every step that needs to be taken
has been bad for him who is this was a
turnout for the books Wow um big broom
energy school projects
she's like I'm bored who are you
flies around on a ma spell just set
people on fire oh yeah she's a great
prank day prank setting someone on fire
I feel like she's gone bud so buddy can
do his magic anywhere now right so
theoretically Liam could go back to the
other world and yeah we could we could
go home and then practice back there I
really love this character of the
incredibly uncomfortable wizard yeah
like hates his own existence but it's
also a magician yeah that should be a
broom really
three little houses um well should we
you show yourself over Therese oh I feel
like we need to do more with Chelsea
Chelsea definitely I think Chelsea had
some yeah she's just swimming at least
let's get her a cat so like cuz Reese
has learned how to one turn into a bat
and also has had a deep drink of
Chelsea's blood yeah
Liam became a wizard and also got
independence you'll see at least we
should get her a cap yeah
I would kept that in there oh yeah I
mean a little tree Liam I'm home I'm a
wizard now go to sleep down in the
street he's good he's already missed the
scuba fly there like Ron did yeah sure
walk through that door hey race I'm a
wizard
good night wait why is he right there
you Muppet
I love it when people fall face-first
onto things okay okay I think we all
know wait magog looks tough isn't that
like a evil god Jerry is Jerry wearing a
cartel he's wearing a polo neck Jerry
looks like he's got a really long smile
like polite cat only we can get up to
three cats oh yeah get on look at Loki
Loki spies are looking the wrong
direction
Loki's always running into walls yeah
Taz is always picking fights you know
what change it a one-seat as
shadowboxing very natural I want to be
anxious oh I think she actually has a
thing for this guy so she's like he's
going yeah yeah dude lady doesn't like
the laptop okay they're all afraid of
the laptop yeah that's weird them all
immediately adopt all three yeah oh
excuse me
oh she's happy
oh because the decoration is nice okay
okay so the cats didn't even matter
adopt what you're gonna do that yep
Loki's face oh yeah yeah so want to keep
Loki
they say that when you adopt an animal
you're supposed to change their name so
that way they don't associate it with
their time but if it's allocated to Loki
maybe roll the student the last name
wants toss Thurmond
oh wait what's the other one gone just
right now is back down and shut shut the
door is worn out they left it's outside
they're indoor/outdoor cats they kind of
[Music]
oh there is yeah
oh all right that's not gonna be good
with vampire general east notices that
that berries over there what why is this
game way you're stacking the blocks
below so avoiding them from hitting you
in the face and now just gonna show up
his house fully nude if you went if you
went back in time to like 1963 and tried
to explain Super Mario 64 to someone I'm
sure it seemed pretty straight goodbye
oh crap she's naked I'm out I'm about
Terry
Stoll I'm back oh wait is he embarrassed
by that
I feel like he's embarrassed oh she
needs to pee well go right ahead was
that blood is that blood on the wall
through the oh wait is that a painting
yeah that was a window and I was like he
made a big mess of it is she gonna pee
oh why she's why's he sad
wait you have to manage the emotions of
the cats now thanks I can pull them over
[Music]
watch me pee wash my hands why do they
not like the laptops I love this cat
nonsense
yes times stray in there mm-hmm I just
like Ellie open and shut the doors
that's my favorite part
what do you want a deer gooo play with
laser pointer change outfit I just like
she's staring in the mirror thinking
about how she has two cats going what
have I done
no they're hungry they're pissed where
was she keeping that laser pointer don't
ask
mm-hmm he's late for school
Cecily yeah he's uncomfortable because
he's hungry she's having a great time
everyone got what they wanted by the end
of it you know like I feel like we did
actually accomplish more than I could
have possibly imagined surprisingly yes
patient's have been realized yeah fully
realized vampire oh yeah goodbye Chuck
I'm always that I'm done yeah he'll
never Liam will never use any of those
spells ever he'll just like die knowing
he's oh is it yeah
yeah it's like me I'm not very good at
mastering any skills but I can learn the
most base level of said skill and then
forget it yeah it's good strategy I know
I know the challenge we were pretty much
out of time but I just want to see what
he can do as a vampire can heap in turn
feed on the cat no offer friendship to
the cat
the cat to know what it feels like to be
an animal cat is so confused have a sack
lunch
alright well joy yeah I'm so curious
about how deep these these things go
it's a vampire eat sack lunch I love
that he turns into a bat for literally
everything like wouldn't you know for
sure now to move to the other side of
the table peanuts
there put some Oh garlic yeah no no he
just cut himself with a knife a PB&J
what's happening with this
okay best variance and then of course
you take all those pieces and pour it on
a plate and you got your sandwich done
wait no can you fly weighs about and
come back you making food or something
for yourself you get distracted me
alright eat the food oh he can't you cuz
it's not blood it's no blood
well walking time I think we've done
pretty well hmmm let's oh wait let's can
you feed on Liam Oh drink plasma yeah
let's do a big drink and let's animal in
the stream on Liam getting Edward Cullen
is looking at girls like Facebook pages
that are feeling
as bad news oh oh no no just the drama
she's like buddy anyway oh no oh wait no
oh passes her wait he's meant to be at
school drink she's going through these
phases of being disgusted and then just
remembering that she's got cats
hot-headed lessen their egos it's whyyy
that's why Liam wears the helmet I think
that seems as good a place as any to end
today's stream at least James thank you
so much for joining us thank you for
having us a lot of fun when you donated
yeah thank you
I think I'm gonna reinstall the Sims you
don't know what you've brought upon
yourself just a weird The Sims give me
yeah
but thank you again for joining us
people in the champ you donated and of
course Duty some James time and I'll be
back again tomorrow with rkg gonna be
doing some geoguessr which is honestly
one of my top 5 things that I've
discovered during quarantine you guys
when played you guess it - I have one
open from before we started this dream I
need to figure out what this highway is
really all right thanks everyone
we'll see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]